the first question you probably asked
yourself at this point how do I access
app engine in the first place well that
is a pretty important question to answer
and we're happy to tell you that it's
super easy so first of all here you are
a star developer and you should already
have a Google account that you probably
use for many different Google services
such as Gmail YouTube Google+ etc well
guess what your standard Google account
also allows you to create App Engine
applications that run on the Google
cloud platform so there is no additional
account required what you do is simply
log on to the developers console that we
will go through later and register the
App Engine applications you want to
create and once you've done that the
time has come for you to create those
great cloud applications so you need to
sit down and hack and hack and hack and
hack until you have something awesome
that you want to test and then you can
fire up an instance of App Engine which
runs on your local development machine
and that is of course great since it
allows you to use all your standard
tools such as debuggers and profilers to
get those bugs out and once you've done
that it's time to run your applications
on computers in the Google Data Centers
so we're just a click or two you can
deploy all of that great code to App
Engine and of course you can have many
applications running there and when you
and your front-end developer friend have
finished your application you tell all
your users about how cool it is and that
they can start using it and when you use
App Engine it's very easy to support any
kind of device and operating system
computer smartphone tablets you name it
and hopefully the users will think your
application is so cool that they will
tell their friends about how cool it is
and hopefully they will tell their
friends and your application goes all
viral and you get all of these great
ratings and recognitions and awards and
stuff but you don't need to worry about
your site going down because it has
become so popular since you built it on
the Google cloud it will scale and scale
and scale on the Google infrastructure
so you get to feel like a million bucks
and become
Rockstar developer that everybody wants
to be with this is exactly what we would
like to happen and that's really what
this is all about App Engine and Google
cloud platform allows you to create
applications that run in Google data
centers and can be used by any device so
you can sit with your laptop and create
apps that scale to serve billions of
users worldwide it's really really cool
where you think about it well hang in
there because you're just about to
create your first App Engine project